economía en france 24 me acompaña el
estudio daniel hablando daniela buena
noche bienvenida y le pregunto cómo se
van a repartir los recursos del
millonario plan de ayudas en eeuu que
fue aprobado hoy hola revolver las
noches primero recordemos que el
congreso de eeuu aprobó el plan de
ayudas por una suma que equivale al
producto interno bruto de méxico perú y
argentina juntos en todo un año para que
haga las cuentas
raúl ahora sólo le falta la firma del
presidente joe parte del total de 1,9
billones de dólares aprobados 400 mil
millones irán a cheques directos de
1.400 dólares por persona que tenga
menos de 75 mil dólares anuales en
ingresos una cantidad un poco menor irá
para los gobiernos locales 170 mil
millones para reapertura de escuelas se
extenderán también los subsidios por
desempleo de 300 dólares semanales hasta
septiembre y una parte irá para el
desarrollo y producción de vacunas se
décima raúl k de este paquete no sólo
ayudará al país sino que implicará un
crecimiento adicional del pib en sus
vecinos méxico y canadá
e indirectamente en muchos otros países
de la región así definirla también el
banco mundial dio a conocer su plan de
asistencia para américa latina en este
2021 si raúl este organismo multilateral
dijo que tiene disponibles 10 mil
millones de dólares para asistencia
económica a países de américa latina en
2021 pero al mismo tiempo pidió mesura a
los gobiernos a la hora de tomar o
refinanciar préstamos esto para evitar
una crisis de deuda y también es un
llamado a quienes prestan ese dinero
escuchemos que llamado eso
y estamos tratando de evitar una
situación en la que la deuda simplemente
se refinancia a una tasa de interés
relativamente alta y luego continúa
creciendo en el futuro eso requiere que
los acreedores oficiales y los del
sector privado trabajen para encontrar
tasas de interés más bajas para las
diversas deudas que agobian a la región
daniela nigeria protestas por el salario
mínimo la historia y la siguiente
después de una huelga general que hubo
en 2018
el presidente de muma hadú boari
promulgó un año después una ley que
duplicó el salario mínimo en el país más
poblado de áfrica hasta lo que hoy son
79 dólares
hoy le suelo intentar repetirse donde a
una manera un poco distinta a cientos de
miembros de sindicatos marcharon hasta
el parlamento de la capital abuja y
amenazaron con volver a la vuelta esta
vez porque en el congreso se discute un
proyecto de ley que sugiere que sean los
36 estados los que establezcan este
ingreso en lugar del gobierno federal
trabajadores creen que esto llevará a
que vuelvan a reducirle su ingreso pues
muchos estados nigerianos han tenido
problemas para pagar a sus funcionarios
en los últimos años daniela y la piña se
convirtió en un producto cargado de
política porque si señor pues en medio
de las discordias que existen entre
china y taiwán
beijing prohibió hace pocos días la
importación de piña desde la isla
citando problemas de plagas en respuesta
a la presidenta taiwanesa lanzó un
desafío en redes sociales raúl a coman
piña hasta que exploten para apoyar a
los productores que ya no pueden enviar
su producto a china beijing ha negado
tener motivaciones políticas y dice que
esta es una medida de bioseguridad
completamente razonable innecesaria pero
el gobierno de taiwán la calificó como
contraria al comercio libre y justo
lo cierto raúl es que la campaña de
taiwanesa provocó un frenesí mediático y
los políticos oficialistas y opositores
acudieron en masa a las plantaciones
para promover su consumo y muchos
restaurantes se unieron también y se
apresuraron a usar esta fruta
como este de taipei que es también lo
sigues àngel indicadores se dio lo que
todo esto y te estaba esperando el
paquete de ayudas que llevó a que el dow
jones de industriales- marcada recortó
en europa también hubo reacciones
favorables al plan de estímulos porque
los beneficia indirectamente y américa
latina también se contagió del júbilo y
sus principales bolsas cerraron en
positivo para finalizar que nuestra el
como cifra el día 1.600 millones de
dólares en ganancias que arrojó la
compañía danesa lego en 2020 con un
aumento del 19 por ciento la pandemia
aumentó el apetito por los famosos
bloques de juguete que fueron lanzados
en 1958 se jugó con legos o no por
supuesto daniela que todo yo creo que
todo niño ha jugado un lego muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información económica a ustedes también
gracias buena noche
[Música]